[Music]  who do you think is the hottest guy  right now in the world uh how is it yeah  who is a physically appealing guy to you  physically appealing guy to me yeah oh  my god it was a typical oh I don't mind  being difficult like if I said to you I  could put you in a movie with so-and-so  who would it be  I mean honestly I'm like somebody likes  like Gordon Ramsay I'm like the last  Gordon Ramsay you're attracted to  hahaha maybe I got a shot with you  Gordon Ramsay that's when you even  physically that's the kind of guy you  would want to be with I mean right now I  could set that up you would go on a date  that's right you're single now right I'm  going to say you ain't the hottest guy  that's who you have that's what you want  to be with Gordon Ramsay